all right Gillian Gillian where'd you
grow up were you from originally
I'm originally from Bremerton Washington
it's a small Navy tonin Washington State
until my childhood you had both your
parents my mom had to work two jobs
because my dad refused to work my dad
was very a very abusive I was abused
when I was eight you molested me when I
was eight he raped me when I was 16 and
he he pretty much terrorized me my mom
and my sister a lot of abuse a lot of
talking and stalking and you know he
made her life miserable and nobody
stopped it or nobody
well we filed charges when I was
molested but they I guess they had him
do some kind of tests but he didn't meet
criteria for his rights to be taken so
we still had to see him and my childhood
was just it was just basically always in
fear always in fear of my dad always
just sad and scared and always unsure
myself sounds all yeah well I got
married when I was 18 or when I was 20
and everything was fine for almost like
11 years and then I left got back into
doing drugs and I just I I completely
went I completely lost my mind
you know I became homeless for the first
time in my life I lived a very sheltered
life like I was never exposed to drugs
or being homeless or anything like that
and um and you know I started
prostituting myself and to try to keep a
man because I I wanted him to be with me
and I felt like if I could bring him
money
and get him rooms and all these things
that he wouldn't leave me and of course
it didn't matter because I was always by
myself you know you know men are you
know a big problem for me because I seek
that love in dollars but I think it's
love and validation where it's it's not
you know where it's just about sex and
what they want from me and and and I've
learned to be ok with it I learned that
I know I probably do have value but I
don't see that inside myself you know
were you doing drugs before you got
married
yeah I started using the house 15 I
tried math when I was 17 his first time
in um everything escalated after my rape
when I was 16 you know I couldn't I
wanted to escape from my life I wanted
to not feel I am I wanted to feel numb
you know what is the drug today um it's
still meth I don't really know on Skid
Row
um no I was living out in Long Beach I
kind of bounced around between Long
Beach I'm skiing you know Depp you know
I've been I haven't been out here in a
minute but I was you know going in this
trap house in South Central in them but
mainly it's been in Long Beach but I
started like losing my mind like
convinced like you know people want me
dead because I was messing with do it
from different games and people have
told me like that's gonna get you caught
up and um and so it's like every day I'm
in fear like something's gonna happen to
me
oh he's in constant fear so what are you
doing for money now um my soul I still
sell my ass I still prostitute myself
for a while I wasn't doing it and then
you know I started doing it again so
that gets dangerous right yeah I mean
nothing nothing crazy like where I've
been held at gunpoint or like what I
hear other women go have gone through
were worse but you know for me it's it's
going to that [ __ ] level of giving
myself to someone that I don't I
normally wouldn't you know contact with
your family still I talked to my mom I
check in with her she's very
disappointed and hurt and she won't see
me I don't talk to my kids you know my
daughter my oldest suffers with
depression and she has a lot of suicidal
ideation because I was affected I'm not
there and you know so where's your
sister - she lives with my mom she
doesn't talk to me either so it's just
basically me you know my friends like
they don't reach out to me you know the
friends I've had and recovery up and off
in the last couple years
oh you've been through yeah I've been in
recovery the left eight years there's
nothing on it basically yeah don't like
amount of time I had was um almost a
year I went out like two days before my
year and that's what I consistently do
I'll get almost a year and then I'll go
out what typically triggers you to go
back relationships those are
relationships I'll get in a relationship
it won't work out
oh it just it hits me to a level where I
can't take it I can't take the pain so I
resort to I start hooking up and then
the hooking up police to me using again
no so do you see your your your
relationship with your father is a big
part of why this is I blocked out what
my dad did I've never really dealt with
what my dad do I mean in my addiction
like I've had countless men like write
me and
do you some [ __ ] up [ __ ] to me and to
me I feel it comes with the territory
it's like I I can talk about being raped
and it's no big it's like it's no big
deal you know because of what I do you
know but um with my dad like I think
it's like I still carry that that pain
you know hmm
what do you what do you wish was I guess
I guess my question what do you wish for
your future
did you have any plans do you have any
goals it's hard to see like past like in
this moment you know my thing is always
I don't want to be on the streets I
don't want to be around anyone that's
gonna [ __ ] hurt me like I'm always
convinced people are gonna [ __ ] hurt
me you know and um so you're just
looking day by day yeah but you know my
goals are like oh I know like this isn't
gonna last forever I know like I want
more for myself I want more for my
children like I want to be there for
them and doesn't know that I I love them
I just you know I want to say that um
like I want to stop and I want to live
differently I want to live my life but
my addiction has such a grip on me and
it has me at it
it has like a rope around my neck and it
they're like controls every aspect of my
life and it's like I've lost sight of
everything
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story
you